So what I just said is that we've got an Ultimaker 3 arriving in here today, or Wednesday. That old thing? We already got it.
No way... what? you guys already got it
No WAY!
So the Ultimaker 3 is one of the best 3D printers you can get.
Oh My God!
But it's important to clarify: We didn't get this from Ultimaker, our friends at matter hacker
Actually gave this to us
if you're printing something that has like an overhang, you need something to support that because it's building it up from the base and the
Cool thing about this printer is the support stuff that it prints is water-soluble
So you don't have to sit there and clip it off and sand off the little bumps on your model this one you just take
It and put it in water and then take it out of water
And you're done. Exactly because it can print two different filaments at the same time
So it prints the regular plastic and then it prints the water-soluble plastic with a separate printhead. Thanks matter hackers
How was your run? Great. Run every morning? Morning run's every single day for the last five years how far was your run? Two and a half miles
you should turn around. ...turn around? ...no
you really should do it!
it's a box! oh
Yeah!
sweet!
Wait, so what's interesting about this is it has really thick filaments. This is what I think the water-soluble stuff
I'm incredibly excited to try this ultimaker out. form two was a wonderful experience as well the form 2 uses a
Liquid based... like laser system, and this is a little more traditional PVA plastic and pla plastic
Yes, a little bit of apples and oranges. They both kind of have their strengths and weaknesses
I'd say the strength of the ultimaker is definitely size. you can build things and print things that are much larger
And less expensive! far more conveniently a lot more conveniently
bzzzzzzz
They're back! whenever someone or all of us leaves our garbage out over a weekend fly spot
don't hit the camera! now fly Huntin season. They're still corpses on my desk right here. Here's one fly there
There's one on the pen.
Dude, why are there so many yeah landed on my face a moment ago? these flies are brave!
can you not...do it here...please stop...
Got him. Got one.
uh...quick start guide. what's in the box?! ultimaker three. remove the packaging install the printer
Copy that all right?
So gently place the printer on its side and dirt the spool holder to the back panel and push it until it snaps
in place
this is the build plate where the plastic
Lives so all the prints are created off this
Open the front build plate clamps. insert the glass plate. make sure the glass plate slides into the rear clamp and close boom clamp
Who knows blow?
Yeah, i hate it. it's like every summer, someone takes it like real stinky food
and they just like they leave it in the bin over the weekend and
and we have flies to deal with it sucks should print some fly swatters. would be pretty funny
yea it would be totally possible the little rods and,  *slap sound*
Think it's a really easy first test and also relevant. ready?
oh
Got him. it's all about that flick it's doing really well, the nerf method is working Flawlessly
YEAH!!
set 'em up....KNOCK 'em down! never going hit it, let me try wake him up.
I thought we can kill them all but there's so many more
Okay, the next step is to load the printer with materials
moving printhead
place the new spool on the spool holder
a little water
got my spool
I insert it into this tiny little slot in the back and just wound it up and shot it through this Tube here
This is a hard material once the material hits the head Gonna start squirting out liquid material
It's feeding yea, it's not doing the turbo feed...the last one It was like
Whoa that noise?
This is a plastic filament that's been extruded at point four millimeters. Oh
Wanna Confirm killer floor holding there be very still
Yeah! OH!
Honestly just think Flytraps
How big is that wire? exactly two millimeters all right cool so fashioned a handle probably twisted it?
twisting it or something i dont know, and I'll just make it sturdy and then uh
I'll just whip something up here
Cool
So this is Roughly 8 by 9 we get doesn't permit sticker. If it does wear yeah, cool figured it out
Yep, got the scaling right not everything right all right? Well, I guess I just turned it on plugged everything in hopefully it works
Yes, your print turned out nice. Yeah, we're a little punk
Bottom due to the high detail kind of like very thin kind of structure right? Oh my God. they're landing on it!
Did you see that? we just made that from scratch. hand crafted. the computers made some polygons, and then hit print oh
dude, You gotta be faster than that. Yeah. Oh, sorry to come back with dangers out there look at that,
he's just going at it! beating the blind. i killed 200 flies!
to one
decision
There's one on your hip no mike almost upon your head almost a parabolic you want. I just shot
You though harmony like hold it up the second team andre?
But you get loaded it and glue them on the fly yeah
Baby, it's like you go to the fly likes goes perfectly through one of the holes is like
So I guess it's a little brittle for a flyswatter, but it's really stylish very stylish flyswatter
I
Still think if you make it like super 10 like maybe like two or three layers thick it'd be able to be flexible enough to
continue being used. there's another one
dude! its, its shattered sorry oh?
Yeah, so one small. i've killed so many flies
so many flies
buzzing around...help me help me
This printer works much differently this uses a pool of plastic to make layers
It will feed liquid into this tray
And there's going to be a little laser underneath it that shoots lasers into the liquid hardening it piece by piece, this allows it to
Create 3D prints with laser accuracy